we don't have a flag but lizard is kind
of our symbol because we wish we could
grow apart like lizards
it's kind of my emotional support
iguana
hi everyone my name is shave I am a man
I thought I was a woman for 10 years I
transitioned started transitioning in my
early 20s
um
initially I was just
gender bending then I would wear
gender non-conforming clothes when I
went to college I grew up in Eastern
Europe but when I went to college in
America I was finally able to wear
things that I wanted to wear which is
expressed myself more feminine
but
um shortly after going to college people
started asking me my pronouns
and I was just I thought it was weird I
knew I was a man I was a gay man and as
I started doing research I started
questioning my gender and thinking that
I was a woman trapped in a man's body
so quickly I have OCD so quickly I got
obsessed with transition
went to Stan Warehouse in Boston was
able to get her hormones rather quickly
uh hormones messed me up actually I
started I became more depressed uh more
sad more suicidal but I attributed it to
being still in the wrong body that I
needed to like complete my transition
so I ended up getting uh facial
feminization surgery which is looking
back at it it sounds sexist like what is
facial feminization women come in
different shapes and colors and sizes uh
and short laughter that I got approved
for
sex or assignment surgery
and I was only approved in 12 visits
is it easy to get
these surgeries uh scheduled it was
relatively easy for me there was
absolutely no pushback by therapists
they completely like ignored or oral
mental comorbivity comorbidities I had
um I'm definitely on a spectrum I have
ADHD I have severe childhood trauma
so I have internalized homophobia they
completely it didn't even push back at
all they said they affirmed me you know
I'm getting the letters for the
surgeries
I was excited what do you think that is
do you think the doctors just want to
make money or do you think
there's a fear of saying oh no you
you've I sing this respect everyone's I
think yeah
a couple of things I play
one saying
radical trans activists have been
pushing for affirmation only model and
general Falls from fanway house in
Boston was one of the hospitals
kind of to Pioneer that affirmation only
model
so any push back often considered
transfer back
in countries like Canada if you try to
give people a little bit of a pushback
and ask them like why do you think
you're a woman what do you think how
does a woman feels because a lot of
people like I Feel Like a Woman
nobody asked me ever those questions
nobody said maybe
you have internalized home before bed
because I grew up in a very homophobic
family where I was brainwashed from
early on that gay is bad and sinful for
what country did you grow up in um I
rather not resilient because a lot of
um my family that's still in that
country
don't know that I'm gay and my my
parents still lives there so but I grew
up in a Muslim family and
I was always told that attraction to men
as a man is bad so the minute I realized
that I could become a woman possibly
I have just latched onto that idea like
I really wanted to be a woman because I
wanted to escape my homosexuality
because I was so brainwashed by my
parents in society but I am not supposed
to be attracted to men as a man
so the mayor that came across as there
was a way to possibly change my sex I
lashed into that idea you know
immediately
and
syrup has never tried to help me tackle
my childhood trauma
my parents had been verbal abusive to me
as a kid you know my mom was very
disappointed that I wasn't masculine
like other boys and I was short so I
should try to she always comparing me to
other masculine boys that I had in my
class you know and I could just tell
that she wasn't like proud of me just
because of the way I am and she kept on
trying to Butch me up you know try to
give me to karate classes she even like
um gave me two classes where I had to do
like stretching try to grow taller
so
um and I got a lot of abuse at school as
well people just kept on calling me
[__] and all the regular things uh
feminine effeminate gay men gay boys
goes through
so that kind of early on sent a message
to me is that I must not be a real man
because of the way I am
and um
it's kind of hard for me to talk about
right now
so I was trying to escape my
homosexuality and my my
Nails I guess because I felt like I
couldn't measure up to other men because
there is a three just three types of a
man in society that you have to be told
masculine at certain way and I just felt
like I could never measure up to that so
the closest point of reference for a
woman I felt safer around them
I felt like they wouldn't be bullying me
they wouldn't be attacking me because
most of bullying and attacking him from
other men
and that made me feel like I had more
kinship with women
so that was another factor that kind of
pushed me into it but back to why it's
affirmation only and why people are
getting fast tracked um to transition
the pipeline it's number one as I said
um therapists are just afraid to
practice anything other than information
presenter labeled as transphobic in
Canada is considered conversion therapy
if you try to push back a little bit
um also there is a lot of money to be
made from insurances through this
hormone therapy affirmation surgeries
for example when I was cleared for the
surgery I know this sounds ridiculous
but nobody even sat me down and told me
that you're gonna have to take hormones
for the rest of your life
I was stupid I was young a lot of trans
women and trans Community things that
estrogen is just for looks but there's
so much more to it you know it
definitely changes the way you feel the
way you sing if you're a man getting
castered with estrogen and in my case I
was a gay man it actually contributed
more to my depression
so yeah and there is now a lot of money
to be made from those affirmation
soldiers because in Massachusetts for
example also pretty much all the
surgeries are covered at this point I
believe it's the same in California
and people are getting those surgeries
and hormones younger and younger and I
transitioned to three spells because I
wanted to just blend in
get away from everyone and just be left
alone because I just feel disappointed
in general by society that was my goal
with transition but as I saw that so
many people were transitioning younger
and younger getting surgeries younger
and younger and also what was happening
with the whole like Leah Thomas
situation trans people competing in
women's sport and winning them I just
felt like I had to say something because
actually after I had a surgery
I spiral into severe depression
um and trans Community there was
gaslighting me and telling me that it
was a possible depression
that it's normal and I have to kind of
like
put new goals ahead of me because
transition was my goal and now it's kind
of not there anymore like I've been
transitioned but depression never went
away and actually I started having
complications right after I had the
surgery no matter how much I dilated and
for those of you who don't know what
dilation is is when you get new Vagina
you stick like firm objects inside of
yourself to keep things open but what
they don't really explain to people is
that your body treats us as a wound and
as horrible as it sounds as just reality
so so you have had breast augmentation
and sexist surgery you had your penis
and testicles removed yeah I had my past
penis and testicles removed I had penile
inversion surgery that's when they slice
up your Johnson and shove it up inside
of you try to create a tunnel but the
point is
it doesn't have the same polluters as
natural cysts I don't like using that
word but natural vagina would have so
you kind of have your body's natural
instances to heal it
so you always have to dilate and one
thing that I realized later on that all
the surgeons have different dilation
schedule which is like a big red flag
how come the surges have been done for
years but there is still like every
surgeon have their own dilation schedule
which is like why is this not more
scientific right now more Universal but
also started coming to me later you know
as I started going more down so now you
now you regret doing these things yeah I
regrets basically just taking estrogen
because it made me confused about my
biological reality because before taking
estrogen when I just socially
transitioned which was I was just
cross-dressing but it wasn't just the
estrogen you you had breasts yeah but I
got breast after estrogen like I was on
estrogen for a year right but you also
chopped off your
I did yeah unfortunately I regretted I
miss my Johnson one of the biggest
mistakes of my life but I think not even
just a surgery I just regret ever
identifying as a woman because I believe
transgender movement is actually
regressive it's so ridiculous to say
that oh you're a woman just because you
have long hair and you have movies you
know it's like man I did I take bigger
guys over 200 pounds a lot of them have
breasts bigger than mine so it's like
it's very aggressive and kind of sexist
it says that oh now I'm a woman because
I'm wearing a skirt and have longer hair
looking back at it it sounds ridiculous
um
so yeah I just regret you from being
part of this movement
that's why for years anyways I struggled
I kept on having more revisions trying
to fix you know because I wanted to be
able to connect
with another person again and have sex
the way I imagined it was supposed to be
in my head because I was so homophobic I
wanted straight sex
um so I ended up having more revisions
ended up getting cold imagine the plus C
whereas they cut out like a piece of
your colon
and try to create like more of a tunnel
in you but that failed as well you know
and
um actually upon revision from that
surgery I ended up with a colorectal
fistula which was completely scary
thankfully I didn't have to wear a
colostomy bag
after that I got very very depressed I
I wanted to you know check out of this
reality
because I just felt like my life was
over
but then I no longer trusted any
therapist because obviously this was
actually the first time I ever gotten
any kind of mental health help was one I
came to us and one through gender clinic
and that's when you know that prescribed
hormones I was after that I kind of did
instruct therapist anymore you know so I
turned to psychedelics I did ayawada
trying to kind of find meaning in my
life
which helped for a while
depression kept on creeping in
and that's why and I started slowly like
realizing that wait a minute this
transition this whole thing didn't bring
me like the trans Joy people talk about
it didn't bring as a gender Euphoria
people talked about
I still if anything could magnified my
gender this word because
when I was just wearing whatever like
gender banging clothes like I was
confident in my manhood yes I was a
feminine man but I could go to a male
bathroom and sometimes men would like
take a double take you know is that a
man is that a woman and he kind of
actually made me happy to kind of like
make people confused a little bit but
after I said transitioning it just
became this all city like on my passing
and people tell I'm a man can people
tell I'm a woman so it's just like it
just makes things worse for me like it
didn't solve any of my issues it made
things worse on me it pulled me away
from my family and friends because it
was just easier to cut people out and
explain to them the whole transition
process
and I'm kind of going through that again
with the transition it's almost easier
to just like not talk to people than
trying to tell them hey by the way like
I'm a man no like just people are
confused they're like oh how are you a
man like you look like a woman but I
just want people to know that woman is
not a love you know it's kind of
offensive to woman so it's just so weird
is that like
um at this point it came to the point in
the timeline where if men were a little
bit of makeup or do something that's not
stereotypical manly people just assume
you're transitioning or you're
non-binary it's almost like this
movement erase androgynous people in
either race gender non-conformity trans
is literally medicalization of gender
non-conformity and trans activists are
always saying that oh Trans people have
been around for years we won't have
transgenocide and all that it's like no
what we had for years and centuries were
gender non-conforming people
cross-dressers Unix trans only it's a
label I personally don't believe anybody
is born trans
um
I believe some people struggle with body
dysmorphia agenda disorders that's
another thing like
psychiatrists never told me that I
possibly have body dysmorphia and as I
start getting this feminization
surgeries I guess like getting breast
work done face work done I still wasn't
feeling sexy I was still not feeling
comfortable in my own body
I still felt ugly and only recently when
I went to a new service last year I
realized like I had a body dysmorphia
that I still don't feel comfortable in
my own body that feelings that are
confused for being in the wrong body it
was because I had body dysmorphia I grew
up chubby I grew up feeling ugly feeling
less and that was really a software
issue and those people just literally
sold me Hardware fix took my insurance
money took years of my life took my
health I have osteoporosis now because
of not having enough hormones in my body
for years I just got back on
testosterone last year and finally got
some of my sex drive back because I
literally felt that inside for years
and nobody even told me hey even if you
were like having the surgery you need
like both hormones in your body because
every person needs some estrogen and
some testosterone just males them to
have average male has more testosterone
as males get older successful level
drops you know so to become more
emotional you know all that so it's all
just kind of like averages and natural
biological processes
so my care has been completely
mishandled all the way from like
um therapists up until even now right
now I won't have I want to have my
breasts removed because
because of my osteoporosis it's very
painful to have this like large heavy
breasts but I can't even get any help
like I don't want to spend eight
thousand dollars in recession to have my
breasts removed and I don't even know a
lot of the transitioners are struggling
getting insurance coverage for reversal
surgeries and to be honest I want public
to know that in certain cases fully
transition is impossible I've been an
indie trans Community for a while and um
I've talked to some of the trans men who
attempted phthaloplasty after
vaginoplasty and it wasn't it was
horrible like one man got phthaloplasty
which like they had to take skin from
somewhere in his body what is it what is
that it's once they take a skin from
your body and try to construct a phallus
a new penis I guess uh or a penis look
alike because you can never get it back
the way it was so they take it it's
multiple surgeries so they take like
skin from somewhere on your body they
put like a penile implants they put like
testicle testicular implants they take
tissue usually something inside of your
mouth try to once in your urethra trans
men who attempt to get bottom surgery
goes through something similar and I
know One D trans man who had it done and
he said it was the most painful surgery
he had even more painful than
vaginoplasty so he actually had to go
back to the doctor and has the phallus
taken apart
I'm not laughing I'm just like it's my
stress to live and put the skin back
where it came from so it's very horrific
surgery is I think general public just
thinks that surgeries have been done for
decades so they must be safe
but the truth of the matter is there is
really no studies showing that
specifically sex reassignment surgery
improves anybody's mental health in fact
there is a Swedish study showing that
within 10 years after
um sexier assignment surgery people
become more suicidal and cancel
themselves but that's
all those studies that contribute to the
mainstream Narrative of happy
transitioners have just kind of been
labeled as transphobic and pushed away
in terms of hormones there is no studies
comparing it to Placebo to even you know
get an idea is it any better than
Placebo usually when you do drug studies
you do compare it to a placebo but
somehow there is like no societies
comparing it to estrogen in terms of
testosterone testosterone has amazing
antidepressive properties so when I went
on testosterone last year I definitely
got a little
my mother has improved a little bit but
it's also traumatic getting your sex
drive back and not having functional
genitals you know
before transition
when I took estrogen
before taking estrogen I was comfortable
with my penis but within a year after
taking estrogen I started hating my
penis I got convinced that it was just
like it needs to go it doesn't belong on
my body every time somebody saw it and
looked at it I was getting very
dysphoric very kind of annoyed so I
literally went from being okay with my
genitals to hating it and wanting it off
my body after a year of estrogen
and I never saw like I would want to you
know talk to someone but now with
testosterone certain desires are coming
back
and it's kind of traumatic
and
I don't know what to do because it's
almost like it brings more attention to
my genitals
and in a way it also makes me sad so I
mean I don't know eventually I may be a
force into like hormone will be
transition whatever that means simply
because it's just so traumatic to be
honest you still seem to be trying to be
a woman because no I'm mistaken I do get
mistaken a lot for a woman and
the way I look at it I don't do pronouns
so if you see me as a woman she heard to
me going ahead and correcting someone
being like Oh you're I'm a Mac homie he
him it's just stupid it's almost uh
equivalent of non-passable trans women
that are walking around where everybody
can clearly see it's a man and they're
just militant about using she her you
just have to be understanding that all
the sight is not gonna come affirm what
you sing in your mind
and it's completely ridiculous and in
Canada for example right now you can go
to jail for misgendering someone
and I know that some people maybe
purposely misgendering somebody to make
fun of them or something but some people
just don't pass you know they just will
never pass no matter how many surgeries
they do and Joel's a trans people
watching this if you're transitioning
just be careful like don't trust
surgeons blindly do your own research
the informed consent that they give you
for surges and hormones be careful read
it very carefully the surgeries yes I'll
tell you this thing can go wrong but if
there is no probabilities next to things
going wrong is this really an informed
consent yes a plane could crash right
now into this building but what are
chances of that and there's literally no
studies
um
on the complication rates and on
satisfaction rate from vaginoplasty in
trans women
um so yeah just be careful if you have
relatives that are planning to
transition try to get some good
therapists I'm not saying that medical
transition can can not help anyone but
it should be like a lost step because a
lot of the things are reversible
and what's your relationship like with
your family
um honestly my homophobic family
initially they were against transition
but then took more like oh it's against
Allah and like you're gonna like you're
gonna go to hell blah blah blah but then
when I transitioned and my relationships
with men started appearing more
heteronormative to them they became more
accepting and
it was pretty traumatic you know I
definitely had a lot of bullying both at
school and from my parents because as I
said they just didn't like the fact that
I was naturally feminine
and natural femininity is something
that's
been around for centuries there's many
different there are men who are gay
there are men who are feminine there are
men who are gay yes there are
cross-dressers there are
people that are
they're trans right transgender but
they're they still have penises then
there are transgender homosexuals I
guess and I think that's a problem
because a few years ago like a decade
ago there was more of Distinction but
now
a lot of people are falling under that
umbrella you know just automatically and
trans communities pushing for even the
ideas that you don't need to have gender
dysphoria to be trans which is crazy
because
original trans activists fought for this
to be classified as mental disorder so
it could be classified a medical
condition and could be treated by
treatments that are covered by insurance
so saying that this is not a mental
disorder is completely crazy if somehow
something inside of you whether it's
innate whether it's induced by Society
or traumatic childhood wants you to
emulate stereotype and stereotype being
a keyword of an opposite sex it's 100 is
a mental disorder and saying otherwise
just sounds ridiculous and again I just
feel like a lot of people are gonna get
hurt with this affirmation only model
people are not given proper mental
health help there is the trans woman in
my community that are missing their
breasts
and they had double mastectomies once
they were underage pretty much you know
they haven't even had a chance to grow
into their Womanhood I even feel like
even though I was 18 plus I feel like I
didn't get a chance to explore my
manhood you know and grow into my
manhood realize that like a lot of my
desire to transition was to sit in
because I was felt like when I was
wearing gender non-conforming clothes I
was getting weird stairs people were
treating me like a creep
um but once I started passing more
I could wear whatever I want and people
didn't bother me you know they didn't
give me dirty looks they didn't make fun
of me
but I don't think that
in the future right now what's happening
with the Trans kids are literally
castrating young gender non-conforming
boys just because the boy wants to play
with a Barbie or wear a skirt and run
around that choose three that doesn't
mean anything this could grow out to be
a drag queen let's just be going through
a face it's completely ridiculous that
just because boy wants to play with
Barbies and wear a skirt and run around
at two or three years old parents of
mentally think oh they have a trans
child on their hands so they must
castrate him with Lupron
uh by the age 11 you know to make sure
the kid doesn't go through puberty it's
completely ridiculous they're castrating
this kid for a look they want to make
sure that his voice doesn't drop they
want to make sure that he can become a
woman look alike but this kid gonna lose
his sexual functionality the head of w
pass which is organizations that set
standards for transgender care came up
released an article if she wants to go
seeing that all the m2fs which is voice
that are seeing their girls and being
castrated with puberty blockers they
will never know what uh orgasm is like
because they never had testosterone in
their body when I had no successor in my
body for years it was so hard to achieve
orgasm I never it was just I wasn't even
thinking about sex my sexual desires
were completely gone so how can kids opt
out of orgasmability which is a natural
human biological function once they
don't really know what it is I think
it's completely unethical
I don't know what's a good solution to
this is because a lot of parents are
being emotionally blackmailed by trans
activists because there's being told
that if you don't transition your child
they'll be at high likelihood of
canceling themselves which is complete
emotional but still
I feel like trans women took away the
diversity we used to have such as
cross-dressers and you know
transvestites all those you know now
it's all just kind of falls under the
same umbrella
and it literally erases it erases will
drag us because now we have trans woman
competing on RuPaul's driveways either
raises woman in a way as well what woman
means it resists homosexuality
um a lot of people from what I realized
in g-trans community
have a lot of other mental issues that
were not resolved and they saw
transition as a way to kill a version of
themselves that was traumatized but the
truth of the matter your issues are
still up here no matter how much we're
modifying your body your trauma doesn't
go away you still have to go within
yourself whether it was a help with
non-biased good therapists whether it's
psychedelics whether it's talk therapy
different things work for different
people but your problems are not going
to go away just because you transition
and yeah that's the conclusion it came
down to and
but again I feel very stuck I don't feel
like fully transition is possible for me
so it's for me the transition is more of
a state of mind just coming to
realization that I've been pretty much
lied to that I'm not a woman
and my blueprint was male and I
destroyed it through surgeries and
hormones
yeah what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in all of
this
this journey of yours don't trust big
Pharma do your own research stop being
radical I think one of the problems
inside right now people are getting
radicalized because radical ideas get a
lot of attention
so just be able to hear like the other
side and see where those people are
coming from and I do believe that truth
is somewhere in the middle and seeing
things black and white has gotten
Humanity in a lot of trouble
and gender exists on a spectrum
feelings change
but biological reality doesn't change
and being medical patient for life and
sleazy big Pharma is not fun so
and it just takes time to find out who
you really are it takes years to realize
who you are to grow stronger and making
permanent life decisions permanent body
modifications earlier in your timeline
it's a really really bad idea
all right yeah
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you so much thank you for having
me thank you lots of luck with your
detransition
thank you